je vous propose de vous rendre tout de
même au château de fougeret dans la
vienne alors le château de fougeret dans
la vienne il est réputé pour être le
château le plus hanté de france et vous
changerez peut-être d'avis en passant
une nuit là-bas regarde le château de
fougeret personne ne veut y habiter les
propriétaires sont persuadés que le lieu
est hanté par des âmes errantes
on est au delà de la mémoire des murs on
parle avec des consciences on leur
demande quelque chose ils nous répondent
les propriétaires nous montre comment il
appelle un esprit si cette personne
accepte de communiquer avec nous et
bakel fasse basculer
ok super la soirée se poursuit au
deuxième
dans le noir on demande aux âmes je te
nous faire un signe et quelques minutes
plus tard alors entendu ouais s'allume
alors là je stresse étions nous seuls
dans cette pièce comme nos guides des
dizaines de visiteurs sont persuadés que
fougerais et tenter alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait on passe la nuit là-bas ou
par jimmy vous pourriez passer une nuit
dans cet dans ce château
avez-vous des défis à la hauteur de mon
talent et passer nuit là-bas où est
l'exploit vous pourriez jamais arrêter
le reportage la table bouge à la touche
et rue je nous on n'a pas si grand comme
ça fait quoi mais je vous assure qu'on
va se cotiser on va vous envoyer la
balle chipée à toi tout mais je le paye
moi je disais il n'y a pas de problème
mais franchement mais quel cinéma ou
d'adultes où on aider des enfants il
faut les rôles et il vaudrait croyez
vraiment que jimmy ouvre ses chakras
il a fallu ferait le plus grand bien
mais j'y crois mais moi je crois le ou
pas jimmy un fantôme m'a sauvé la vie
pardo enfin on va trouver la vie jouer
avant pâques d'accord oui alors vous
explique mais je suis en voiture
oui je roule déjà seul dans la voiture
depuis bien trois quatre heures la nuit
est tombée depuis longtemps je suis je
vais là comme ça vers la normandie et je
sens que je commence à m'assoupir je le
sens mais je me dis je suis plus forte
que ça on y va je suis pas très loin je
vais y arriver des draps et là tout d'un
coup et je sens que je m'assoupis
j'entends une voix qui vient
la radio est content
réveille-toi réveille toi il faut aussi
arriver là où droite qu'est ce que c'est
que ça et je me retourne et là j'ai un
fantôme
je vous assure que j'ai entendu dire si
à la place du passager
non mais j me parler je lui dis attendez
qu'ils ok ok par le mois il faut que
j'arrive je serais vraiment en dieu
enfin bon quand même vous discuté
pendant trois quarts d'heure et un auto
stoppeur le gard
[Rires]
je suis arrivé ça défoule personne n'a
jamais capable ressembler à moi j'y
crois car était une sorte de forme mais
vraiment il y avait quelque chose quand
même quasiment d'assange envoyer mails
j'ai d'avant a parlé du vent l aviez vu
[Rires]
comment je compte également où passe
tout de suite pour une haine ou pour une
illuminée alors franchement d'accord
très bien et il avait un prénom les
fantômes externe
j'ai eu un peu peur au début mais
finalement on s'habitue on s'est côtoyé
on est devenus mais je vais mais vous
n'avez pas demandé ce qu'il foutait là
non mais tu as écouté par le mois par le
moi savoir le fait qui me plaît le
permettait de rester éveillé les
fantômes des bagnoles on le connaît
ludivine est ce que nous y croyez vous
on plaisante mais bien sûr il ya des
gens qui ont vraiment sûrs ont des
histoires absolument incroyable comme la
vôtre et qui sont absolument persuadé
que le monde de l'au delà nous parle
mais totalement écoutez je viens d anti
madame beinheim comment vous dire
les esprits les sorciers les trucs des
rites votre mort yahia fasse passer
énormément de probes et d'y croire parce
que vous venez d'annoncer dénonce ma non
seulement j'y crois mais en plus j'ai 40
anecdote à raconter aux enfers une
peut-être mais on n'a pas tant elle est
là mais j'ai pris un jour alors je vous
explique ma mère vit dans le dans le
nord caraïbe le nord de lille il ya un
immense virage avant qu avant de grandes
distilleries avant d'arriver je vous
jure il rit souvent non mais j'avais pas
vu je ne cherche avait pas but j'avais
18 ans je venais d'avoir mon permis on
était en bande on sortait de soirée je
vous jure sur ma vie que c'était le
virage sans fin pendant une demi-heure
chaque fois je sortais je vais jure sur
ma mère de deux enfants j'ai deux
enfants de l'aja dans leur tête à chaque
fois que j'arrivais au bout du virage et
une grande descente et à chaque fois et
à chaque fois que j'y arrive on se
retrouve en haut de la pente mes
cousines ma copine et moi je vous jure
c'est vrai à chaque feuille sorcier de
bois toutes les trois ans sortait de
boîte mais j'avais à peine l'âge de
boire je venais d'avoir mon public
j'adore vos histoires sont votre miroir
mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai et vous savez ce qui m'a
sauvée alors moi j'ai pas eu de fantômes
et où moi je vous jure que j'ai pris et
je me suis arrêté et je me suis mise à
prier à voix haute et la prière sa
chasse les mauvais esprits heureusement
que je suis là ma la bd d'amiens pour
terminer peut-être alors non moi je ne
suis pas entier mais le secteur de
l'hôtellerie est un univers très
concurrentiel on se rend compte que
beaucoup d'établissements mise sur
l'insolite et moi je soupçonne en fait
cet établissement de miser sur le côté
rapport avec l'au-delà contact avec des
fantômes d'un passé c'est bien mais moi
je pense que c'est de la pub apparemment
avec des vraies expériences
non mais je pense que tout est monté de
toutes pièces effectivement comme les
jeans et je pense qu'il ya un genou sous
les tables ou quelque chose un mécanisme
enfin il ya quelque chose ne tourner les
tables parler aux esprits moi je fais
tourner les serviettes pendant le soir
vous a posé les maisons hantées j'y
crois je n'y crois pas et vous nous avez
dit souvent fonctionné
eh bien voyez le condamnons vous voilà
eh ben vous croyez à 57% vous ne croyez
pas à 43% ça représente un petit peu ce
qui se passe ici